It does need to be now what,
what do you think is causing autism?
And in your personal estimation,
do you think that it is a,
that there is a rise in the factors that are causing autism?
Or do you think that it's a rise in the understanding of these variables that
contribute to it that you could diagnose people with in that before they were
previously undiagnosed?
So I think most of it is that,
that we're just diagnosing it more.
We're including individuals in the autism category that we didn't before.
And by the way,
the numbers are about to go up even more because we're getting better at
diagnosing girls and women with autism,
which is also quite interesting.
We used to say it was 10 to one boys to girls and now we know there are a lot
more girls and women on the autism spectrum.
It just that they're usually more verbal and they can camouflage it better,
but they have very high rates of Comorbidities,
like obsessive compulsive disorder,
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder.
A lot of the teenage girls with eating disorders now they're finding could
actually be on the autism spectrum.
So the numbers are about to go up again.
I mean that's just an example.
I mean is I guess what you're really trying to get at is that,
is it beyond that?
Is there,
is there a bonafide increase beyond the number of diagnoses?
And in that one I'm still not sure about,
yeah.
I ran an article about early onset gender dysphoria being connected to young
girls with autism.
Right?
Yep.
There's a disproportionate number of girls with gender dysphoria who turned out
to be also autistic.
Right.
I've heard that as well.
Yeah,
that's actually,
so it's really fascinating to think about now.
Unfortunate and fascinating at the same time,
right?
There's,
there's um,
there's a nice paper by very good environmental scientist and Phil Landrigan who
used to be at Mount Sinai now,
I think he's at Boston College now,
and he publishes about five or six chemicals in the environment,
which if you're exposed to for long periods of time during early pregnancy,
your child will be born with some features that resemble autism.
Do you know what those chemicals,
so I have to remember all I talk about him in the book.
On one of them is Depakote,
valproic acid,
which is a psychiatric medicine used as a mood stabilizer or an antidepressant.
So prolonged use of depakote during pregnancy has been linked to something that
resembles autism.
So that common medications,
a common medication.
Um,
but now that we know this information,
we don't use it anymore.
And so one of the things that I've been saying to,
you know,
people like Bobby Kennedy and everything else,
if you really want,
if you really think there's some environmental link to autism,
we've got a list of at least six chemicals during early exposure in pregnancy
that are probably causing mutations and things like that that are leading to
autism.
Why aren't we,
why isn't anybody looking into that?
It's just crazy.
I mean,
so all the focus on those into vaccines and it kind of sucks all the action out
of the room so that,
you know,
really understanding the search for autism gets delayed or in some cases doesn't
get pursued at all.
Or the other thing that happens in many state legislatures and things like that,
the focus is so much about vaccines that we don't talk about.
What autism parents really need.
I mean,
what do I need for Rachel?
We need,
you know,
employment counseling and help.
We need mental health counseling.
What do we do after we're gone?
Rachel right now is living with us.
I'm s I turned 60,
my wife is 58.
What happens to us 10,
15,
20 years from now?
There's no roadmap.
Where's the so,
so all of that gets shunted aside because of these phony Baloney anti vaccine
argument.
And that's why I get angry.
That's when I start to realize these guys in addition to affecting public health
are actually hurting autism families as well.
Well that makes sense.
I mean,
I can completely understand why this sort upset you,
especially as a scientist.
Now when you're talking about these,
uh,
various chemicals that you think do contribute to or possibly cause autism,
um,
maybe we should really concentrate on that and publish something about this.
Is this something that,
is there an article that people can go to that says something about that?
There is,
I talk about it in the book,
in the book,
and I could,
if I opened up the book,
I could provide it for you.
Um,
is there anything that people can read online about this without going to your
book?
Um,
probably,
you know,
one of the problems that we face in this country is that we put a lot of
scientific articles behind paywalls,
which is a real source of frustration for me.
And that's what they do that,
well,
one of the reasons,
one of the things that I've done now is,
um,
I'm one of the,
uh,
I founded a,
an open access journal called the public library science neglected tropical
diseases so that anybody with a computer,
you know,
an Internet connection and a printer can download the articles for your charge.
And we need more of that.